get out of the car
shocking body camera footage shows the
moments a police officer opens fire on a
pair of teenagers in a McDonald's
parking lot
it happened in San Antonio Texas on
October 2nd just before 10 30 that
evening officials received a call for a
disturbance at a local McDonald's when
Officer James Brenard responded to the
call he noticed a vehicle that was
involved in a separate incident I got a
vehicle over here that uh fled for me
the other day he's in the parking lot
[Music]
after calling for backup Brenard walked
over to the vehicle and opened the door
get out of the car body camera video
shows the driver later identified as
seventeen-year-old Eric Cantu with a
stunned look on his face in what appears
to be a McDonald's meal in his lap after
just one second of delay Cantu puts the
vehicle in reverse and attempts to drive
off
the vehicle's open door hits Brennard
and he opens fire when Cantu continues
driving off Brenard opens fire for a
second time
after that Brennard begins chasing the
vehicle
[Applause]
shots fired
Cantu and the 17 year old girl in the
passenger seat were pulled over on a
nearby Street can't you was taken to the
hospital to be treated for critical
injuries he was later charged with
evading detention with a vehicle and
assault on a peace officer
get out of the car Brenard was treated
on the scene for injuries sustained when
cantu's car door hit his legs after an
internal Review San Antonio police
announced Brenard was fired from the
force they say he was still in a
probationary period having only served
for seven months at the time for the
latest developments in this story and
all things True Crime stay with long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie